so so question how many bodies is too
many bodies how many bodies is too many
bodies
damn i have to give a hard line
responsible you you could say plus or
minus like you know roughly
i think
the age i'm at now
mid to late 20s
i think anything in the in london
because everyone will lie about the body
count i know where the people are on in
school
below 10 is good
10 to 15
is okay and then below 20 is like
you wouldn't agree with it but you'd
accept it because i've come to realize
having done numbers myself mm-hmm
[Music]
so many people lie that is
yeah and especially i've got one thing
i've come to the realization as well
is that cool say at one point i was
chopping out and going through but the
reality is
is these same women were probably
getting chopped out by guys like me who
were just time wasters so probably from
what i'm attracted to is like echo
chambers like i could go to for that
nerdy girl who plays chess and her body
counts probably below free
but then like if i tried to put my thumb
in her bum she might be like whoa what's
going on so
[Laughter]
what about what about you um i'd say
below 10.
yeah
um
it's a wife
yeah oh it's a wife yeah um
yeah i'm gonna say below 10.
no questions
part of it what i say to the mandem yeah
i find with a lot of men a lot of men
think they're the guy in it i'm not
saying you might not the guy but a lot
of men will say mad numbers like r5
because i've slept with ten and part of
it is the insecurity of like wait if
she's on the same numbers at me it's the
realization that maybe they're not the
guy
so do you think that plays into it as
well because i know a bag of man i slept
with like say less than 10 and they're
like no i have to be like three but
that's like a [ __ ] in their masculinity
what do you mean think on that
wait could you just reframe that in like
a simpler context like because i that
was so long-winded but i kind of get
what you're talking about what i'm
trying to say is like do you think that
that is based on that figure alone or is
it any way related to yours
oh okay
yeah all right i think it's related but
it's more like
i'm assuming you would i be correct and
saying you wouldn't be with someone that
slept with more
people than you yeah am i correcting
saying that correct so do you think say
i don't know what if he would say if it
was say a hundred yeah do you think that
figure would be higher
yes
yeah yeah that's what i find with a lot
of men is that a lot of men they
wouldn't go for someone who's near them
because a lot of men they think they're
the guy
and the fact that a woman an attractive
woman has slept with near the same
amount of bodies as you
maybe you're not as special as you think
um my my kind of uh dictation on numbers
is based on like math i'm thinking
all right under 10 or under single
digits
she's probably got
some way
to kind of pair bond with me
at a point where it's not a case where
her whole hair bonding process is gone
she she's less likely to be alpha
widowed
and like i don't and i don't know at
what level
uh she's been alphawood like i might say
oh i've alpha widowed a girl yeah but
then
the guy that afforded her is on a next
thing but one thing i'll say in this
london year
the only way to really find that is to
find girls of a long-term relationship
if that's what you value yeah because
say we're you're around mid-20s say you
really
lose your virginity at say 16 which is
the average in this country that most
girls lose it at yeah if you do one a
year
for
up to the age of now that's
10.
but the reality is we know what girls
get onto when they find their sexuality
in terms of in uni etc and i just know
so many girls because i had a lot of
female friends
so many women just lie
and they just play the game so it's like
we'll say this is too much but the
reality is you don't even really know i
mean ignorance is bliss if you're not
but i think you also want someone with
like similar morals to you i guess
especially if
if that's what they were doing at uni
you can't just wipe out that aspect of
your personality they might be more
likely to cheat later on if yeah no i
agree i would agree if you're more
promiscuous you're probably more likely
to
well i think that's why guys stay
younger
yeah yeah they do but less baggage less
yeah less bodies less stress and like
it's
it's it's it's a newer model wouldn't it
one thing the eye
um one thing that i kind of do when
dating a girl i'll literally look at her
friends
i'll be like birds are the same feathers
plot together oh 100 so so more time if
a girl's like hiding
her promiscuity i will literally look at
her friends how are her friends moving
and like usually she's got
two or three her friends
and i'm like oh so this is what you guys
are on
and now you're showing me a version that
doesn't look anything like your friends
yeah 100 i i won't even test the waters
because i'll know that i she'll she'll
pull a fast one on me would you say
though
because i see what you're saying but i
just think men have a lot to lose
nowadays
when it comes to like paternity flaw
fraud you know um
paternity fraud they said cuck-holdery
and divorce grape is a grim reality for
men cuckold like wait uh where's this
cockholdin
bad so is russell wilson like a [ __ ]
sort of when you think about it like
because he he's a [ __ ]
you know you know is like and and don't
get me wrong like he's very respectable
and like all he's accomplished he's like
a one percent dude but it's it's sad
when you see a one percent dude wife a
hoe
it's just like you could yeah
it's not like i didn't have options as
well um why is she a hoe
because she i mean she dated like every
rapper before she don't respect him as
well yeah and and if you watch could you
pull up the ish could you pull up a
video of the video of her on top of the
car because i think that that would be a
good one to show i thought she said the
goodies stayed in the jar
i'm a slag and i love [ __ ] never
the real ones
um sierra
i'm gonna pull it out but basically like
the the the idea is like can you turn a
home into a housewife
and and the thing is like your habits
are who you are so if a girl's been
doing something for 10 years
like is she gonna magically stop one day
probably not
it's the same thing with a guy if he's
cheated in every single relationship
he's been and he's probably going to
cheat on you too
i disagree and see people can change
i think the man can change the demand
can grow man yeah
but i think the
the
actions of
um either being a hoe like what comes
with it it may manifest in different
areas she may not go out and do the
things but it may
may how do i explain it
it can
it can be in different areas of her life
so
if even in guys in with cheating if they
don't if they say okay i'm not going to
cheat on my wife if they don't fix it if
they don't work on it and change it it
can
manifest in different ways it may not be
in cheating but it may not it may be in
different areas and work in other
relationships they may be just dodgy in
however they approach different things
it shall send it to you in the dms i got
you
i just found it uh